deflation is literally just a lowering
of prices or a general decrease in the
level of price for goods and services or
another way to think about it since
inflation is an increase in the level of
prices you can just view it as negative
negative inflation and so let's say you
wear the wear the folks at the Bureau of
Labor Statistics and we're trying to
compute the CPI index and in one period
let's call this period 1 over here we
have our CPI index for urban consumers
and that's the one that's quoted most
often and we have this basket of goods
and it'll have housing in it it'll have
housing let me write housing like that
let me write that a little bit neater
it'll have housing in it it'll have
transportation in it it'll have fuel in
it it might have some proxy for
entertainment or whatever else inside of
it and that basket of goods let's say in
period 1 and this is a simplification
runs that urban consumer on average 100
dollars and then we go to period 2 and
we look at that same basket of goods
maybe we're adjusting certain things
maybe some products have become obsolete
we have to replace or there has to be
some adjustments for technology and
that's all under debate what how you
should adjust them but given that
assuming everything else is equal that
same basket of goods is now running at
98 dollars and so the total cost of
goods and services for this kind of
average consumer has gone down by has
gone down by two dollars or we could say
that we've experienced negative two
percent inflation which is really just
another way of saying that we have
another way of saying that we have
experienced deflation now deflation is
not the norm
especially for growing economies the way
that our current economic systems run
although it does happen and a pan in
particular is probably the most recent
most famous case of deflation and the
main reason why economists really don't
like deflation or I should say in
particular while sent why central
bankers really don't like deflation is
that it makes it much harder to control
the economy or the fueled economy with
interest rates alone or
be just with printing money alone and
I'll go into a little bit more depth
with that in future videos
one thing I do want to make clear is
although deflation isn't what we
normally see in the broader economy as a
whole it does happen very frequently in
specific sectors and the most common one
is in the technology sector in specific
specifically hardware we've all
experienced buying a laptop one at one
period so this is right now you buy the
laptop for maybe $1,000 and then six
months later six months later you see
that exact same laptop for five hundred
dollars and that's just because the rate
of technological innovation is good at
going so fast that they can produce the
same amount of memory and processing
power for a lot cheaper now or for the
same amount of money you can get much
more memory and processing power and all
of the rest and you see this with
laptops and with with with big-screen
TVs and and and phones and all the rest